[Music]
Tyler Perry we saw that he went ahead
and got you a Tesla you as someone that
has lived out of their car and it has
come this far and Tyler he's someone who
believed in you tell me your initial
reaction because I saw you get a little
emotional
okay he sent me the video a week ago and
I was like I felt like and I cried so I
cried so hard because you know crying is
nothing but a removal of old beliefs and
a replacement of new ones right and it
was a belief said like oh somebody will
do something nice for you just because
you are you you know and I always had a
belief that if somebody wants to do
something I have to do like a thousand
nice things I have to be really nice in
order for somebody to do something nice
for me and I just did my job it's the
best of my capacity and if for him to be
that kind to me and not expect anything
from me but what I've already given like
that like it filled my whole heart up
and then when I saw the car for real
life-like cuz I thought it was a joke at
first I was like I'm gonna cry off this
job but like damn it was real it's real
if the man looks too good to be true
before I let you go I want to play a
signature game a she ready game okay
okay so tell me is she ready for Meryl
Streep as her mom and girls trip - yes
she is ready for marriage trip as her
mom and girls trip - yes is she ready to
remarry she ready to remarry if he got
better credit in here good man and you
said you're ready for Leonardo - crappy
other video baby daddy
she ready for Leonardo DiCaprio to be
baby daddy but I don't know all things
Leonardo ready he now ready ready got a
lot going I might be too aggressive I
gotta work on
[Music]
[Applause]